I'm gonna talk about the three
situations where you would not want to
take apple cider vinegar or any type of
acidifier but I do want to mention that
most people benefit greatly by taking
out cider vinegar simply because most
people don't have the normal stomach
acid they need in the stomach to digest
normally your pH should be between 1 & 3
which is extremely acid but as we age
and we consume junk foods the pH and
stomach increases and becomes more
alkaline so now we lose our ability to
digest especially protein okay
and also we lose our ability to kill
microbes we also lose our ability to
absorb minerals and if we can't digest
protein fully it ends up undigested
lower in the digestive tract and then
you get all sorts of bloating and
problems but there are three main
situations that you would want to avoid
adding vinegar to your diet one is if
you have an ulcer now how do you know if
you have an ulcer well one simple way is
to take some up soda vinegar like you
would always want to dilute it take a
tablespoon or two in some water and
drink it if this makes your symptoms
worse you could have an ulcer okay
because you're dumping acid into your
stomach on an open wound and that's
gonna make things a lot worse there's a
really good remedy for ulcers zinc
carnosine you take fifty milligrams
three times a day works like a charm
take this dosage for a month and then
you can reduce it with a blend of all of
the trace minerals because anytime you
take one trace mineral without all of
the trace minerals you control things
either out of balance another thing to
help ulcers would be to take chlorophyll
okay
wheatgrass juice powder is loaded with
chlorophyll you'd mix up with water
drink it on empty stomach very very good
for all sirs and of course if you're new
to my channel you definitely need to do
healthy ki tale in a minute fasting
because that will give your body a
chance to heal and eat the right foods
to avoid this problem in the future
now the next situation is gastritis
this is a situation where the stomach is
inflamed and you're getting like a sour
regurgitation of acid that comes up to
the esophagus so if this stomach is
inflamed and you add more acid it's
going to make it worse a good remedy for
this condition is DGL licorice
probiotics unless you have C Bo if
you're not familiar with this I put a
video down below to learn more about it
and it wouldn't hurt to take zinc
carnosine for this condition as well in
addition to that marshmallow root is
also good for gastritis and the other
condition is called zollinger-ellison
syndrome where you have a tumor which is
usually in around the pancreas it could
be in the small intestine that is
causing a greatly increased production
of gastric acid which is causing an
officer so the great majority of the
population will benefit from this that
you're always going to have a percentage
that is not going to benefit thanks for
watching so if you want more knowledge
on how to create a healthy body
subscribe now and get daily
notifications